the Pythagoras theorem is by far the
most important concept not only in
triangles but also in the entire field
of mathematics to understand it all we
need to do is draw a right triangle it
is a triangle in which one angle is a
right angle
what's so special about this triangle or
this theorem the first thing we need to
understand is what the side opposite to
the right angle is called it's called
the hypotenuse the Pythagoras theorem
says that the hypotenuse has a special
relation with the other two sides it
tells us that the square of this length
that is the hypotenuse squared is equal
to the sum of the squares of the other
two sides remember it holds true only in
the case of a right triangle so the
theorem says that for any right triangle
the square of the hypotenuse is equal to
the sum of the squares of the other two
sides let's say the lengths of the sides
are a B and C C is the length of the
hypotenuse for this triangle we can say
that C squared is equal to a squared
plus B squared if this is a right angle
triangle the square of this length will
always equal the sum of the squares of
each of these lengths this theorem has
innumerable uses so let's look at one in
this video
Zara wanted to build a ramp leading from
the ground to the back porch the porch
is three feet off the ground
and due to building regulations the ramp
must start seven feet away from the base
of the porch how long will the ramp be
using the Pythagoras theorem we can say
that the square of the length of this
ramp will equal three squared plus seven
squared the square root of this sum will
give us the length of the ramp
you